the jurgen experience
it's really bad dude i got one for you
because you got me watching those
[ __ ]
videos animals eating first of all
i love bears but i can't watch them kill
anything because they've seen the recent
one they don't bear
took
well they just they kill it because they
start eating it before it's dead
they just hold it down and start eating
yeah that's what bears do
i got one for you okay have you watched
the praying mantises videos
yes i have do you see the one where the
praying mantis eats the lizard and tries
to eat him
well he because he [ __ ] alligator
armed it he was like i'm gonna kill you
he kind of did the little flicky he gave
him a little jab and then that thing
just grabbed him he was like
ah what the [ __ ] yeah liked and then
started looked at him then he started
yeah but his jaw but if he let his hands
go as you guys say with his tongue
i think he could have pulled that thing
in and crushed him
no no a praying mantis is so [ __ ]
strong
they're so much stronger than you would
imagine them being because they have
these little stick arms
yeah that i watched one eat a
hummingbird oh yeah yeah they ate all
kinds of [ __ ]
they had everything that they get a hold
of we're lucky they're little praying
mantises are amazing
i [ __ ] love those little things
they're they're crazy what they can do
to
a bird or something much larger than the
lizard was the most impressive
because the lizard thought it was going
to eat him and that thing was totally
immobilized
yeah it was like it reminded me of
watching the [ __ ] that you say well he's
passed his guard yeah now he's going for
this that thing was just like oh it's
exactly like that
because the the their clamp is so it's
like
if somebody got you in a darce it's the
same thing if someone
gets like uh like this grip and then
cinches it up to a darts choke you're
like trapped in there that's what it was
like he was there it is
this is poor [ __ ] look he thinks he's
gonna get him and he's like [ __ ] you
ain't getting nothing
but look how he holds his mouth open and
then he's like oh dude i i hate i feel
so strange but this lizard get he gets
away he gets away for a second
but this is what's crazy second yeah
yeah yeah look at the yeah
he starts eating his mouth he just
starts sliding i know what he's doing
joe
i know have you ever seen uh praying
mantis versus a murder hornet
you know everybody's afraid of murder
hornets look at him he's like [ __ ] what
did you do to my face oh
jesus he's like in pain he's shaking it
off and the praying mantis is like [ __ ]
i'm not done with you yet
like he's in agony and he's spazzing
around and the praying man is just
locks onto him again and slowly starts
pulling him apart
and at the end he's dead he just starts
eating his brain
look at that they just can pull that
skin apart and bite right through it
but it thinks so much bigger than him
that's like you eating a cow
that's like you holding a cow down now
look at that
he's eating his [ __ ] brain lizard's
dead as [ __ ]
well that that part's not a problem for
me right here because now it's dead
yeah but it died this way i know it did
that was the part of it i love it
i'm a big fan of the praying mantis i
like the technique
i'm not going to begrudge i just i don't
need this
the video the grizzly uh taking down the
buffalo was only two days ago it was in
yellowstone it linked me to a 30-minute
video of it just [ __ ] up all sorts of
animal or
pregnancies yeah i'll put that one by
the way there's so many [ __ ] people
there it goes what's this what's he
[ __ ] up to all kinds of things
leaf bubble what is that it's a leaf bug
i think oh wow what a weird looking
creature
oh prank mantis is pink he's uh he's
camouflaged himself oh wow now he's the
color of the leaf
yeah this is a good point 10 million
views on this prank mantis video
they're amazing animals man what were
you going to say were you mad about
i wasn't mad about anything i'm just
like i you know
i love bears right yes i love when they
ride the bikes at the [ __ ] circus
[Laughter]
i love when they ride the bike in the
circus
this is my thing about that what did
they have to do to that bear
when you see what this thing can do to a
bison what did they do to that
bear to get them to get on a [ __ ]
bicycle give them food
that's how they train them is that how
you did it you got a bear in the back
just the confidence the way you said
that because i've seen that you've
i've seen the train bears yeah they can
train are you one of those guys who
doesn't need any sleep like of all the
random [ __ ] things i've seen it
this is the one with the bear oh with
the whip that little whip there
is this on a bike i don't think he
freaks out
i don't think he's beating the bear i'll
tell you right now that guy's not
dressed to get a [ __ ]
to be attacked by a bear no well the
bear's got a muzzle on
and it's a little ass bear but
embarrassed dude [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you they got the they got the
freddy krueger claws
on all he got four of them he's on a
vespa now look at that
wow i mean can you humiliate a bear even
more
he's got to wear that frilly outfit now
you got him didn't give him a motivation
someone who's a big fan of the bears
riding bikes i was joking
me just joking i didn't i didn't know
maybe i actually watched a whole
training video
of how like that's where do you find
what part of the internet are you on
well i don't know i was i was trying to
figure out why people
what the [ __ ] that guy's got a giant
grizzly bear on the back of his bike
playing a horn it's playing a trumpet
because he got any volume on this
trumpet let me hear this
oh back it up there
hello
this person that's filming this is an
idiot you think it can't break out of
that seat belt and just
did you see the bear flipping them off
that thing has on a [ __ ] lap belt
yeah what is the bear doing that he's
just imagine this got to be russia right
the only way they would allow this is in
russia yeah
yeah look at the language in the back of
that tree he's yelling at the [ __ ]
traffic
jesus christ is [ __ ] go size of that
[ __ ] thing
my god just throwing his arms up just
thinking about ripping a person apart
no he is yeah he's thinking like i used
to be in the woods i could [ __ ] eat
whatever i wanted
the weird thing about bears is if you
train them when they're young they're
like almost like dogs
they become your buddy
it's a weird day somebody tells that
bear that it's riding [ __ ]
that guy [ __ ] that guy riding the
motorcycle
his gun it's gonna be in trouble
you